hello everybody and welcome to part 10
of our n ltk with python financial
language processing tutorial video in
this video we're going to be talking
about word net so word net is probably
one of the largest not really corpus but
the largest I suppose capability corpus
corpora that you're going to be given
with n ltk so with word net what you can
do is you can take words and you can
look up synonyms to words and antonyms
and definitions and then even context of
that word so let's go ahead and just
dive in so there's a bunch of stuff to
do so first we're going to do from ltk
corpus we're going to import or Dannette
now this import takes a few seconds
depending on your computer so just be
patient with it
then let's say we want some synonyms or
since that's basically so sins equals
word net dots in sets and then you can
put in the word here let's use the word
program because program actually has a
lot of meanings it could mean a lot of
things so we'll do that and let's go
ahead and just print sins okay so here
we have some sin sin sets or sin set
yeah sin sets so it's just a list right
it's a list of these sin sets and you'll
see later on that we can end up using
this right here as a search parameter
down the line anyway so you can see that
for program we have things like plan
program broadcast and that's because
program has many different meanings so
you can see we actually put a few
program nouns but plan broadcast course
of study it's the only other ones I see
anyways those are sin sets and then
obviously since it's a list you could
reference an element in that list so you
say the zeroeth element now we can also
get say we want like maybe just the word
so we could do something like this so we
can say print
since 0 dot lemmas um well first we
should probably we do dot let's do that
lemmas so see what that gives us first
so we want is your with element but
right so some lemons for this are like
plan plan in plan with a special
spelling of programa anyway lemmas zero
and then dot name like that so you can
get just plan and then if um may or may
not be able to actually get away with
doing dot name here as well let's try
that right so here the problem is you're
getting just you're getting like the
whole sin set the sunset name is this
not this was the name for the lemma is
going to be just that like an actual
word so anyways there's that since just
the word just for some notation there
now um let's take it a little further
and do like a definition so we can print
a sins 0 die definition talking parms
okay this will give us the definition
for the specific word that we're looking
at it so this one is for plan it's a
series of steps to be carried out or
goals to be accomplished okay that makes
sense so then what we can do is we can
also do examples so like I was saying
before in context so we can do sins zero
diet
save and run that let me pull this up a
little bit they draw up a or they drew
up a six step plan
they discussed plans for a new bond
issue okay so that makes sense so now we
could do this for any of the elements in
the list but then what if we wanted to
have synonyms and antonyms well we can I
guess we'll leave this stuff here it's
okay so I always post the source code
but if you want you can delete this
stuff and it'll kind of make some space
for you but I'm going to do this yes so
now we're going to say synonyms equals
an empty list and two names equals an
empty list and then we're going to say
for sin inward net dot sins sets and
we're going to use the word good since
it has good synonyms and antonyms force
in inward net since that's good and then
we're going to say for um L for lemma in
single Emma's what do we want to do here
we're going to say synonyms dot append L
name because again lemma is if you
remember are like synonyms so we're just
going to treat them like synonyms and
then if there are any l dot antonyms
whoops that'll be empty forms there
we're going to say ants and two names
append l antonyms empty parameters
element 0 dot name okay so l antonyms 0
so that should kind of be like right
here basically ulemas 0 name will print
out a little bit more at a time after we
run through this one time so you can see
what each step of the way is doing but
for now let's go ahead and print set
synonyms and let's print the set of
antonyms
let's fix print
antonyms print print save and run that
drink some coffee okay
okay so we have synonyms which is these
are synonyms so thoroughly full skillful
well beneficial trade good so obviously
this is a synonym for the literally the
term good as in goods or services so
trade good secure safe okay
all the stuff synonyms to good then you
have antonyms to good evilness ill bad
evil badness okay so you're gonna get
synonyms and antonyms but again because
we're using lemmas which are like
synonyms it's not going to be just
synonyms for just the term good as in
good or bad to me good as in good good
or service and that kind of stuff so
there's that let us for each step of the
way we can print let's say we don't need
to do sin for that because we already
we've seen what word night that sin sets
gives us but and then sin lemmas let's
print L here I'm going to comment this
out just so you can see the L so this
will be L : that and then synonyms we
append if L de antonyms then we're just
appending the Antonine so really the
only thing that you haven't seen
directly would be sin dot lemmas but of
course we have that right here so this
like sins 0 dot lemmas we were taking
just the first lemma but this actually
could be a list of lemmas so we'll
actually will do this real quick and
hopefully get a list right so these are
your your all of your possible lemmas
all right so it's a lot of them anyway
so that is a word net up to this point
for synonyms antonyms all that i'm going
to leave this here now i'm going to
actually get rid of this print statement
we don't need that anymore and we'll
leave these now i'm going to create a
little bit more space and then now we're
going to talk about
it's a similarity so this will be
semantic similarity so to do that let's
first start with two words so we're
going to work one equals and word two is
going to equal something word one will
say is word net dots in set and we'll
use a ship a noun and we'll just use
zero one the first the first one there
must be one okay for a noun for ship and
then for word net we'll say we're net
dots in set and then we'll use boat
noun and the first one again just so we
know that it's going to be one like
there's there might may or may not be a
boat nine eleven right but there's
definitely a ship or boat one okay so
anyway now what we can do is we can
compare the similarity between these two
words
to find the semantic similarity so we're
going to print and what we do is print
w1 what and this stands for whoo and
Palmer and they have a wound Palmer
wrote a paper like early 90s about
semantic similarity between words and
this is kind uses the method that they
used
so we'll say were what underscore
similarity and then you compare its
similarity to what so comparing the
similarity of word one to word two and
let's just try that one out first
so this will be like a percentage
right so they're saying these are 90%
basically similar so now and I'm sorry I
guess it's not a percentage it'll be a
decimal where one is 100% and so you
multiply this by 100 anyway so that's 90
percent similar well that sounded
that sounds pretty successful so let's
try a few so let's just copy this paste
and paste
let's do ship and car and ship and cat
shall we wait for it okay ship in car
are 69% and shipping cat or 32 that
sounds about right because shipping boat
90% accurate or 90% similar or really 91
why is that because they are basically
the same thing
shipping car 69 almost 70 percent
similar most likely because they're you
know a vehicle let's say and then
shipping cat definitely not really that
similar so 32 percent that's
understandable ship and how about a
cactus 38 so shipment a ship is more
similar to a cactus than a cat makes
total sense anyway so that's how you can
do some similarity between words if you
find yourself needing to do something
like that so one might what might people
use since sets for and NLT k+ and sets
Plus maybe words similarity you can
actually use it for two different things
one is to rewrite things so when you
have um there's businesses that will for
example sell you like term papers and
stuff for school so if you have to write
a term paper sometimes you can go online
you can just buy one right not
advocating for that but a lot of times
what those services are going to do is
they'll take someone will submit their
term paper and then they use some form
of natural language processing start
switching words around okay so they take
it and they start changing words that
way they can sell this to like
five ten kids and they have hopefully a
different paper but then what the other
people can do is the school's can come
by read the paper and then use you know
the the exact same methodology only
reversed to find out who has been just
simply switching words around so they
can use similarity to figure out are
people just switching synonyms and stuff
like this or you know the other thing
you can do is you can use an antonym and
you say not sometimes depending on what
the what the word is right so if it's an
action let's say you can flip it or a
description you can flip it stuff like
that but anyway so if you want to catch
people who are cheating or you want to
cheat on your term papers this is
probably pretty common same thing with
like people that write news BOTS and
where the news bar writes you know
there's people that make websites that
are completely controlled by robots or
not reponsible computers right and they
write articles but the way that we write
articles they read other people's
articles that switch a few things around
post up that article and claim it as
their own so that's another example of
how they might do that and then Google
again will come through and in there at
least their goal I don't think they're
very good at at this point but they seem
to be pretty good at not getting bought
websites up but they can do the exact
same opposite and check it against other
people's content anyway pretty cool
stuff there pretty simple the word
similarity I think is a pretty hard one
to write yourself synonyms antonyms
pretty hard you'd have to build your own
word net and why would you you already
have one and that's about it
I think the lemmas is useful obviously
but anyways a lot of really powerful
things that you can do with word nets so
hopefully you enjoyed if you have any
questions or comments please feel free
to leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time